- Good afternoon, and
welcome to Radcliffe.
My name is Janet Rich-Edwards,
and I am the life sciences
director for the Radcliffe
Institute's programs here,
and I also happen to
be an epidemiologist.
It has been my great
pleasure this year
that our science theme
has been on epidemics.
We launched this
back in the fall
with the daylong symposium,
and we've had several lectures
over the course of the year on
epidemiology and epidemics--
everything from small fiber
neuropathy, which is a pain
condition, to the
epidemic of obesity,
and we've also had the Detroit
public health commissioner
and current candidate
for governor of Michigan
talk about the
epidemic of poverty
and how that affects our health.
Today-- I want to tell
you that if you're
interested in any of
those, they're all online
at radcliffe.harvard.edu.
So if you're an epidemics
fan, you know where to go.
I know many of
you are here today
for this particular topic,
which affects so many of us--
affects us personally.
It affects our families.
I think it's very big
in our public concern
and public imagination.
So it's a particular pleasure
to welcome Dr. Albert Hofman
to give a speech to us today.
An MD PhD, he's the chair of
the Department of Epidemiology
and the Stephen B. Kay family
professor of public health
and clinical epidemiology at
the Harvard T.H. Chan School
of Public Health, so
right across the river.
Dr. Hofman was the chairman of
the department of epidemiology
of Erasmus University
in Rotterdam
before we snagged him.
He has been the science
director of the Graduate School
in Netherlands-- sorry, for
the Netherlands Institute
for Health Sciences since it
started in 1990 until 2015.
He's also well-known
to us epidemiologists
as the initiator of two
population-based cohorts
of very large studies
in Rotterdam--
the Rotterdam study,
which started in 1990,
and the Generation
R study in 2002.
These studies, these
large cohort studies,
target multiple common
diseases, have extensive state
of the art assessment of
the putative determinants
of those diseases, and
employ new technologies
in the setting of epidemiologic
population studies.
Important for today,
Dr. Hofman is also
the initiator of the recently
established Alzheimer Cohorts
Consortium.
His current research
focuses on the intersection
of public health and
clinical medicine.
We will listen to Dr. Hofman
for a good 45 minutes,
much of this time,
and then we'll
open it for questions, which
I'm sure many of you will have.
And we will, I think,
put a mike in the center.
When you go to
answer a question,
do us the favor of
telling us who you are
and keep questions
brief, because I think
there will be a lot of them.
So with no further
ado, please join me
in welcoming Dr. Hofman.
[APPLAUSE]
- Yes, indeed.
Dr. Rich-Edwards--
Janet, I can say,
it's a great pleasure
to be here-- an honor
to be at Radcliffe, also talking
about my favorite research
topic, Alzheimer's disease,
indeed, as an epidemic.
And before I will show
you some evidence of that,
I would like to show
you two slides that
are my favorite ones and
explain, to a certain degree,
what we are talking about.
These slides gives
you life expectancy
at birth in record countries,
since we have good records.
You see here in about
1600, the records
come from France and England.
Average life expectancy
at birth was about 35.
We lived up till 35.
Most of us would have
been dead by now.
At 1800, something very
spectacular starts.
You see this increase
in life expectancy.
I took this from a
paper from Jim Vaupel,
an American demographer
working in Germany,
and it's a beautiful paper.
I decided to take
the original one.
But it went on until now 2015.
You see an increase in life
expectancy from about 35
till now in the record
country, 90 years of age
in women, just last
year, first time, 98,
in the record country Japan.
Similarly in Spain.
This is just, I
think, unbelievable.
From 35 to 90 in two
centuries in our species.
This has never, of
course, happened before.
It means, by the
way, that this line--
every four years, we add
one year in life expectancy.
Every four years,
there's one year added.
I summarized this for myself.
You live a week, and
you gain a weekend.
[LAUGHTER]
This is what it is.
This is men and
women separately.
Here you are.
Women, and here you
are, men-- men, blue.
Women live, on average
in record countries,
about five years longer
on average than men.
This explains a thing that
we will talk about later.
And you see also that the
slopes are about the same.
Their four years and one
year is about the same.
There are two
moments of exception.
Here, this is the Spanish flu--
1918, 1919, '17, '18, '19.
And this is the epidemic
of heart disease--
myocardial infarction,
acute coronary syndrome,
as we would say now.
But that's particularly in men.
But then on track again.
Living one week and
gaining a weekend.
In fact, the only exception
added to the two exceptions
that we have is
currently going on
because of the opioid
epidemic-- one of the epidemics
also to be discussed.
That is a decline
in life expectancy.
Overall, the trend is
very, very much upwards
in life expectancy.
Now, you immediately
see this is a triumph.
This is a societal
triumph at large,
but there is a counter
side, and that's this one.
This is a slide
taken from a study.
Janet referred to it.
The Rotterdam study-- it's
a town in the Netherlands,
my home country at that time.
And we did a study
in which we basically
examined all 15,000 people
in one district that
were 50 years or over.
We knocked on all doors,
and nearly everybody
participated in that
study, and we looked then
whether they could make
the diagnosis of dementia.
This was not just
on questionnaires.
No, there was a
neurologist involved,
there were imaging
studies, and so on.
And then you see from a low
prevalence absolute number
of people that have the disease,
the proportion of people having
the disease, it goes up till,
at the age of 95, to one in two.
That means that if we
live long enough, that
is to say up till
90, 95, perhaps 100,
our [? foreland ?] is
perhaps a one in two chance
to have dementia or
Alzheimer's disease.
I use the terms more or
less interchangeably here.
This is why we sit and talk
about an epidemic here.
We made a calculation
for the world.
Epidemiologists like to do that.
And here-- this is some
number of years ago--
this is what we saw in 2001.
This is what we, in fact,
see now approximately.
And this is what we will
see 20 years from now.
You see that in--
of course, all continents
there is an increase,
but the particular increases
are in China and also
in North and Latin America.
This has to do with
changes in population,
particularly an increase of
the proportion of elderly
in a population.
Now when you see a thing
like this, or in particular
when you see a pattern like
this-- this strong increase
with age.
The very natural
question of someone--
you don't have to be a scientist
for that-- is to ask yourself,
why is this?
Why is there such an
increase with age?
And so that is the question.
Why is there this Alzheimer
or this dementia epidemic?
I'm afraid I cannot give
you the answer, and you may,
if you wish, still leave.
Perhaps I oversold the title.
But I can tell you that
I know why it is not.
It is not because of this.
It is not because of aging.
Before that, I tell you why
I think that's the case.
I perhaps have to
explain a little bit more
about what we mean by aging.
There are two ways that
you can look at aging--
population aging and
individual aging.
Population aging
effectively, essentially
is a demographic phenomenon.
It is the phenomenon in
which what you see here--
people grow older.
A population grows older.
The proportion of elderly
in a population goes up--
the so-called--
freeze-- rectangularization
of mortality.
The compression of mortality.
This is the most quoted paper
in our local journal, the New
England Journal of
Medicine, the highest
journal that you want to
publish in in medicine at large.
It's the most quoted
paper, and reasonably so,
because this idea of
rectangularization
here in 1900--
50% dead at about the age of 50.
In 1980, what was it?
About 70 or so.
And now we are up to 80 overall,
perhaps, and it goes on.
This is demography.
This is population aging--
a very reasonable and
important concept,
particularly in demography.
Then we have individual aging.
Now individual aging-- you
can think of in two ways.
And I propose for your
consideration that one is false
and the other is a
reasonable way to look at it.
One is the so-called
gerontologic view.
It is the view that there is
an innate process of aging that
produces this-- this type
of hair color or wrinkles
or brain failure or heart
failure or liver failure
or what have you.
There's an innate process.
We have protocols, so to speak.
We are designed to age, and then
at the end, it fails and falls.
And then there's the other view.
There is the geriatric view--
namely, the idea that
there is accumulated risk.
It is not that we are programmed
to have these diseases.
No, there is accumulation
of various risk factors
that may lead then to brain
failure, heart failure, liver
failure.
This is a very
important distinction
because for a researcher,
the first few view
would mean that we want to look
at what is the aging process--
causes of the aging process.
The second view means that
we look at specific causes
for the disease--
specific causes that may occur
over a lifetime and, in fact,
generally occur over
a lifetime and that
lead then to a
particular disease.
Now, I think that this is
the most reasonable view.
In fact, I think
this view that there
is an aging process is
actually completely untenable.
You find it often.
These are two recent papers--
wrote very recent, I must say.
I did not give you the authors
to protect their privacy,
but it says, "We investigated
the aging process."
You see, in Science,
given the language.
"To elucidate disease causes."
And then the authors go on
to discuss longevity, life
expectancy.
And here in Nature.
"C. elegans--" Elegans is a
little worm, a little nematode,
that is used very often
to study longevity, life
expectancy-- to study aging and
its pathologic consequences.
And then the authors go on to
study life expectancy again.
In fact, it is indeed possible
to change the life expectancy
of this C. elegans [? with ?]
[? effect of ?] three, four,
five, given particular
environmental circumstances.
But not aging.
He does not study aging.
Now, I'm not the
first one to say
that this overall idea that
there is no such thing as aging
is untenable.
So Peter Medawar, Nobel Prize
winner in immunology-- in fact,
he worked on
transplant immunology
in Britain, in Cambridge.
He gave his inaugural lecture
at University College in London
under the title "An Unsolved
Problem in Biology,"
and he explains there
that when we have problems
later on in life, it is
because of this accumulated
risk and various combined
risk factors over a lifetime.
And then his two
colleagues, but also
particularly our
colleagues, epidemiologist
Richard Peter and
Richard Doll, the ones
that basically nailed smoking
to be the cause of lung cancer--
one of those, they did--
wrote a paper, "There is
No Such Thing as Aging"
in the British Medical Journal
quite a number of years ago.
So this overall idea that
there is no such thing as aging
and that when we want to study
the consequences of living
longer that we have to
study specific causes
is not a new idea at all.
And I follow it.
So that brings me then, of
course, to the question.
What then, if you
say it's not aging--
what can then be the causes?
A category, of course,
is that we immediately
think of nowadays, and I
think rightly so, is this.
Genes.
Is it that genetic
factors, genes,
cause Alzheimer's disease?
Is it, in fact, a
genetic disease?
If you want to study
a question like that,
you can do it in
a variety of ways.
We, in epidemiology, we did this
in the medicine first looking
at family history of patients
with Alzheimer's disease
or dementia.
You would expect people who
have suffered from dementia
that in their families,
if it's genetic,
there is more of the disease.
It can also, of
course, be nurture,
but it has to be more in a
family when it is genetic.
Then there was a
second, very important--
and that, by the way,
this is three, four times.
If you have a first-degree
family member with dementia,
you have three, or times
the risk of dementia
or Alzheimer's disease yourself.
Then there was a very
important observation
in patients' children
with Down syndrome
that had died at an early age.
And in examining the brains
compared to children who had
died for another reason
at approximately same age,
changes in the brain-- the
so-called plaques and tangles
that had been described
by Alzheimer--
Alzheimer's disease-- were very,
very, very much more prevalent,
occurring more in the
brains of Down's children
than in reference children.
Now that lead colleagues, when
they wanted to study genes,
to chromosome 21, because
Down syndrome, of course--
you have a triple chromosome
21, and this was then
the first paper
that looked at that
and found a gene related
to Alzheimer's disease--
the amyloid.
Amyloid precursor protein
gene chromosome 21.
John Hardy, still working
at that time in Britain,
then entered the US,
and now back in Britain.
Beautiful paper.
Nature.
Two other genes at
the same time found--
PS1, PS2.
So indeed, we had three
genes around the beginning
of the '90s of the
last century that
were related to Alzheimer's
disease and dementia.
The only consideration
that was of importance
that was that this
represented less
than a tenth of a percent--
one in thousand of all patients.
This is really, really very much
of a minority consideration--
the three of them together.
Well, we wanted then
to make the next step,
and that is a step we could make
because we got new technology.
And this is a theme I would
also elaborate a little bit
on-- the importance of
technology for medicine
at large.
Medical research epidemiology
as well-- population studies.
It's enormous, and this
is an example of this.
Genome-wide association
studies could only
be done because the whole
genomic technology had
been developed.
And basically, what you do-- you
have a large group of patients
with a disease.
You compare it to patients
who do not have the disease,
and you look at all
genetic variants
that are different
between the two groups.
This is not very much--
how shall I say--
on the basis of a very
specific hypothesis.
On the contrary, it is what
we call hypothesis-free.
And when you look at
those different groups
when using this
technology, you find
this is the first
paper that published.
It was published on this-- one
the genome-wide association
study, you find, in
this case, 10 genes.
And then all the
studies were combined.
There are now about 30--
a bit more than 30 genes
known that are involved
in Alzheimer's disease.
By the way, you
see the three genes
that I mentioned to you before
are not on here because they
are too rare.
These are a bit more frequent.
A bit more frequent, although
I will argue that also these
will not, in themselves,
explain the majority
of Alzheimer's
disease or dementia.
In fact, it is considerably less
than a quarter, I would think.
Now, we do not, of course study
genes for the sake of genes.
We want to find something
and understand something
about the disease.
And here is a kind of scheme.
I don't want to go
into much detail,
but that may lead to thinking
about how this disease occurs
and how genes can be involved.
There are two pathways.
One pathway has to do with how
the synapses in your neurons--
in your brain-- how the
neurons are connected.
This is a very clear
thing that goes
wrong in Alzheimer's disease.
And there are quite
a number of genes
that we know now that have to
do with this so-called synaptic
dysfunction.
Then there is an
other set of genes
that have to do with
the immune response
and inflammatory factors--
our immune responses too
strong or not strong enough--
are involved.
We know that in
Alzheimer's disease.
And here are some of the genes
that are related to that.
So these genes have
led to pathways
that are now further
investigated in the lab
and in population studies,
by the way, as well.
I showed you, by the
way, this technology--
the technology that we use now--
15 years ago one snip, one
little variant, took about--
in, say, 10,000 people.
That's what you want to
do in population studies--
took about six months, perhaps
a bit longer, to investigate.
Now we do this in a
matter of microseconds
because it is so fast now.
There has been an
enormous scaling up.
So genes, indeed, are involved
but to a modest degree--
limited.
That brings is of course
to our next question,
the non-genetic factors.
What are the other
possible factors
that are causing Alzheimer's
disease or dementia?
This slide is a bit of a
testimonium paupertatis,
perhaps.
This slide I made over 25
years ago, and it still works.
And we are a bit
better, but, well.
Traumatic factors.
You have heard, perhaps, about
the trauma-- head trauma,
the dementia pugilistica.
You've heard about that as a
possible model for dementia
and Alzheimer's disease.
You've heard about
the NFL and a model
for Alzheimer's
disease or dementia.
Perhaps not.
It's very interesting.
One of the biomarkers
that we study now,
and is quite strongly
associated and possibly linked,
in that sense, with Alzheimer's
disease, is called NFL--
the Neurofilament Light.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't show a slide,
but it's very interesting
because it combines the
evidence that the trauma that
is on your neurons, and it
combines in a kind of summary.
And it's quite strongly
related to dementia
and Alzheimer's disease.
So yes, possibly
traumatic factors.
Endocrine factors.
Hormones.
Yes.
Although you will
see in some time
now whether there are
differences between men
and women in that, perhaps.
Inflammatory factors,
already mentioned those.
Indeed, immunologic
differences-- factors
play a role in
Alzheimer's disease.
It's been discussed and
studied really extensively
now in the past, what
is it, five years or so,
and I'm quite sure we'll
get further in that.
And I would like to focus
on these-- vascular factors,
your overall circulation.
And I do this perhaps under--
here are vascular
factors, by the way,
before I give you the question.
Stroke, cerebrovascular
stroke, atrial fibrillation.
Diabetes mellitus is a
strong vascular factor.
It has a strong effect
on the circulation.
And atherosclerosis--
hardening of the arteries.
Atherosclerosis-- important one.
I could summarize this
section under this question.
Namely, was Kraepelin right?
Who was Kraepelin
to begin with--
before we say
whether he was right.
This was Kraepelin.
Kraepelin was a
German psychiatrist--
neurologist,
psychiatrist, [INAUDIBLE]
arts, as they would call it
at that time, combination
of neurosciences or psychiatry.
He was at the beginning
of the 20th century.
He was at the same
time proximate
contemporary of Sigmund Freud,
and they were not friends,
I can tell you.
He is-- if you have heard
of the DSM, the Diagnostic
and Statistical
Manual in psychiatry--
this is the classification
in psychiatry.
He started this.
He was the one to
work with that first
and build up the
whole classification.
Kraepelin said around--
I cannot exactly tell you that
because it's undated in his
memoirs--
but it must have
been around 1910.
He said, "I have a wonderful
coworker, Alois Alzheimer.
He worked with me in Heidelberg,
and when I went to Munich
he came with me and
formed the lab there.
And Alzheimer, as
a neuropathologist,
has found these very
specific changes
in the brain of his patients."
It's plaques and tangles.
And this is wonderful.
It's wonderful.
We get insight in
there, but we all know--
this is the German
professor speaking--
we all know that
dementia, largely,
is a matter of
arteriosclerosis--
hardening of the arteries,
of the small arteries.
We all know that in 1910.
So let me try to see
whether Kraepelin was right.
Before that, I show you also
here is Kraepelin again--
Emil Kraepelin, Alois Alzheimer.
Here is Nissl and [INAUDIBLE].
For you who are a
bit in neuroscience,
this is a who is
who in neuroscience
at the beginning of
the 20th century.
They sit here, by the
way-- sorry that I
slide this digression.
They sit here south of Munich
in front of the Starnberger--
this is a bad picture, though.
You cannot see it, but the
Starnberger See, the lake,
is behind that.
And this was an important
lake because the reason
that Kraepelin and
also Alzheimer went
to Munich from Heidelberg was
that they needed the successor
in psychiatry, the
professor of psychiatry,
because the previous one had
died because he walked together
with King Ludwig the second
into the Starnberger See,
and they both drowned.
King Ludwig the second is
very often referred to as mad.
King Ludwig-- you have
seen movies, probably.
You've seen perhaps
the castles in--
or pictures of it--
in the south of Germany.
It's a bit Disneyland
avant la lettre, actually.
And so the reason that Kraepelin
and also Alzheimer were there
to begin with was that
the King had died.
Now, when we looked at this
in this Rotterdam study
that Janet referred
to, we found this.
Here is what you look at.
This is an artery.
This is the internal
carotid artery.
This is a bit not so good,
although a clinical neurologist
would see this in you or me,
would say, nah, not so much
to worry about.
The moment the lumen here
gets closed for more than 80%
or 90%, then we
get into trouble,
but this is not something
very much to worry about.
Still this here is a plaque.
Here also.
This predicts dementia
and Alzheimer's disease
really quite well.
It is if you are in the upper
third of this with this plaque
you have three times or so the
risk of Alzheimer's disease.
Given that the overall risk
is already relatively high,
that means that quite
a number of people
have this because
of atherosclerosis.
Their link was atherosclerosis.
A typical-- this is
three, what I say.
A typical strength of
the link with a gene
would be something
like 1.1 here or so.
So that is really
quite a difference.
Now, other studies we could
do looking at these vascular
factors are, in fact, again
a new technology-- not so new
anymore, of course.
This is an MRI machine.
This was the first
MRI machine that
was installed in a population.
And here you have images
like this, all types.
You can see it's a
beautiful device, actually,
and we can learn even more than
we have learned until now, I'm
quite sure.
This-- what you see here
is a little infarct--
the brain infarct.
Something here is our
so-called white matter lesions.
These lesions, a brain infarct,
and this don't particularly
give symptoms.
So it is not that you have to--
you see it in patients, so no,
but still they are quite
predictive of both dementia,
depression, and stroke.
Two or three times the
risk when you have those.
Now given that if you look at
people, say, between 50 and 70,
at least 40% has these
small brain infarcts.
This, again, is a
very good reason
as a marker for the occurrence
of Alzheimer's disease
and dementia.
Now, final part.
I would like to
tell you something
about a possible more
optimistic viewpoint on dementia
and Alzheimer's disease, namely
whether that perhaps there's
a decline in dementia.
And we could study this in the
so-called Alzheimer Cohorts
Consortium, which brings the
various population cohorts,
groups of people that have
been studied, worldwide-- well,
worldwide, in this case,
particularly means North
America and Western Europe--
brings it together and tells
us what overall evidence
we have for that.
Now here is, first of all,
the incidence rate with age.
I showed you on my first slide
the so-called prevalence.
Prevalence is the number
of existing patients,
but this is the
force of morbidity.
Now, how many new cases
will be there every year?
Say new patients.
This tells you much more about
what the possible causes are,
and here they are.
This is the overall in the
various studies that are here.
Overall, you see
it in the same way.
Strong increase with
age, as to be expected,
because if the underlying
number of new cases
goes up then, of course,
also the prevalence--
existing cases-- go up.
And you see here very
strong increase with age.
But no difference
between men and women.
Here is women.
What is it, red or brown?
And here are men,
exactly the same.
So if you have read
this weekend an op
ed piece in the newspaper
that generally specializes now
in fake news-- no, no,
joke, the New York Times.
But if you read a piece
of one of our colleagues
who says we should study
the differences in dementia
between men and women, perhaps
you have a question by that.
Not that there is not--
there are differences,
of course,
between men and women in
the frequency of Alzheimer's
disease and dementia.
In fact there are
many more women
who have Alzheimer's
disease than men,
but that's because
women live longer,
not because the underlying
force for the disease
is different between
men and women.
So if you say we want
to particularly study
what we need to do to have care
of patients, and in that sense,
there's a difference between
men and women, most certainly,
but in causes, it's unlikely,
at least on this basis,
that these causes are
very different between men
and women.
Now if you now look at possible
changes in this incidence--
which is the true measure
that we want to use,
incidence, the
force of morbidity,
we could study this in
this Rotterdam study
comparing two cohorts 1992
2001 and 2002 to 2010.
And we could not only look at
changes in vascular factors
but also in imaging markers,
which is a very objective way
to look at the brain.
And of course, that's
the incidence, the number
of new cases, of dementia.
And what we observed
over that period
was a 20% decline in the disease
over a period of 10 years.
Some time later, our
colleagues here in Framingham--
a wonderful study going
on already from 1948
in the town of Framingham,
not so far from here--
same observation.
About a 20% decline per decade
in dementia and Alzheimer's
disease.
When we combined this
for the various cohorts,
and you see them here.
This is relatively recent.
You see here indeed an overall--
perhaps about 20%,
perhaps a bit less--
decline, if you
look at the various.
This is a study in France.
This is in Sweden.
This is Framingham.
This is a study in Britain.
3C, France.
Overall, very similar studies
but also a overall effect
of about 20% decline.
[INAUDIBLE] this was for what
I showed you before, men, now.
And this is for women--
very similar results there.
Optimistic in that sense,
leading us, of course,
to our next question.
Why is this?
And I would like to link this.
I will not further develop that.
I'd like to link this to
what I said before-- namely,
it is very likely that if you
have changes in these vascular
factors over time--
genes haven't changed
over this period,
but these vascular
factors have changed.
The amount of
atherosclerosis, possibly,
has declined on the
basis of better treatment
of high cholesterol statins,
high blood pressure, less
smoking.
So it's very likely.
I think, that the
overall reason--
one of the major overall
reasons why we have dementia
is chronic hypoperfusion.
Just for 20, 30, 40 years--
not enough blood in your brain.
Not that it's 50% less.
No, perhaps 10% less,
but chronic, chronic,
chronic, then gradually,
on that basis,
neuronal death, leading
then to dementia
and Alzheimer's disease.
And to beat that, this
chronic hypoperfusion,
is basically to beat
atherosclerosis.
It's to treat high blood
pressure, hypercholesterolemia,
diabetes mellitus,
not to forget.
Treat it well, and it's likely
that without us focusing very
much on that-- we did that for
reasons of preventing heart
disease and stroke--
but in the process
we possibly also have
prevented quite a number
of dementia cases.
This does not mean, by
the way, this trend--
down 10%-- does not
mean that we will have,
in absolute numbers, much
less dementia patients.
This has to do with the fact
that we still live longer.
Remember, live a
week, gain a weekend.
And the price we--
so we, in some senses, pay for
that, given the current state,
is that we will have
more dementia cases.
But the trends-- the
overall underlying trends
in the incidence is in
the right direction.
Let me summarize what I said.
First of all, I hope I showed
to you, as an epidemiologist,
that these population
cohort studies are really
a very, very important
resource for our knowledge.
In fact, many things we
know in medicine at large
and in specific areas we know
because of these population
studies.
And I always like to thank
particularly our colleagues
in Framingham for going on
for 60, 70 years with this.
This is quite amazing
that you keep a study--
I know this.
I did-- how to keep that going.
That is really quite remarkable.
And this is one example
that I'm-- other examples,
obviously, now as well.
Secondly, the new technologies.
We cannot do without
these new technologies,
and these are really very,
very, very important.
They help us very
much, and I'm therefore
optimistic overall
on there that we
will find more
causes of dementia
and know also the combination of
these causes, the interaction,
because of these
new technologies.
I would like you to consider,
at least, that there
is no such thing as aging--
that the fact that
we get wrinkles
and so on and also
diseases in old age
is because of
accumulation of factors
that cause these specific
diseases or these wrinkles
or what have you.
I would also suggest that
the role of genes in dementia
is limited.
In fact, I would even
say it's quite small.
I don't think that the
main story of dementia when
it's-- the book is written.
We'll have a short
chapter on genes,
but there will be
many other chapters
with other causes, of which
I think vascular factors are
important ones.
But overall, these are
preventable causes,
I would think.
So the overall potential
that we have, as a society
and in medicine, is that we can
use these factors to prevent
dementia.
That is the step forward.
That is the way
forward, I should say.
And finally, my apologies
for speaking a bit prodomal,
but I cannot resist this.
Epidemiologists.
It's a wonderful field.
It is such a spectacularly
wonderful field.
And when you see the
results of epidemiology,
they occur very slowly.
It is for our PhD students and,
well, from [? us. ?] Janet,
I'm quite sure, feels the same.
It takes so long.
But the effect, overall,
on clinical medicine,
on treatment, on prevention
in community medicine is vast.
I thank the two organizations
that help me to do the things,
and, of course, the
many, many colleagues
that I work with, particularly
our PhD students and post-docs
that I worked with
over all these years.
And I thank you, of course,
not only for inviting me--
for listening to me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Hi.
My name is Helen [? Abrams, ?]
and I have two questions.
One is I noticed that on
the picture of the genes,
that the APOE gene was
going through the roof,
and I wondered if you
thought that was significant.
- Yep.
- And then I had
a question about--
everybody feels that the
creation of the plaques
and tangles and everything else
starts early, and so what's
the correlation between
preventing Alzheimer's and just
the reality that it may
already be starting it
or it may already exist?
- Yep.
APOE, the APOE gene is
a very important one.
I showed you three very
small ones, APP, PS1, PS2--
very small.
APOE is bigger, and among us,
as we sit here, about 15% of us
have at least one allele of
this APOE, and perhaps 1%
have double dose of APOE.
And that-- the double dose--
increases the risk about
four to five times.
It's associated with that.
It's not absolutely
clear why that is.
It is most likely
largely related, again,
to lipid metabolism and
thereby, indirectly,
to vascular factors.
And that brings me to
your second question.
Namely, if you say
this all, does it not
start very early in life?
And the answer is I'm
afraid, yes, it does.
It's very likely, I
think, if this idea
of chronic hypoperfusion--
too little perfusion-- if
that's a reasonable idea,
that that starts very early on.
So that's why the life
course approach in is--
trying to prevent this
from an early age onward,
is a very fruitful one.
And so I propose that
for your consideration.
There's another
little thing there--
why the life course is good.
If you look at the genes in this
case involved in brain volume
early in life--
brain volume at
births in particular--
and you look at brain
volume, atrophy of the brain,
at aged 80 or 90, they
have one gene in common--
the so-called MAPT gene,
which is also the tau gene.
So that means that
one of these tangles--
the plaques and the tangles--
that [? amyloid ?]
described indeed
is related to one of the genes.
So I'm not pushing
away all genes,
but there is, also in genes, a
kind of life course, it seems.
In any event, it
mean, most likely,
if you want to protect
your brain later on,
start very early in life.
- Two related questions.
I wonder if you think
United States society
today needs to do
more than it is doing
in the area of prevention.
And secondly, I
wonder what you think
of the movement that is
called the Bredesen Protocols?
- As a guest here--
I feel myself very
much as a guest
in this beautiful country--
I've worked so long with
many colleagues in the US,
I am not going to say anything
very specific on the US.
I think my US colleagues
should do this.
But yes, I think
prevention is, in nearly
every respect in medicine, in
disease, is the way forward.
And do we do enough?
You won't, you know.
I have to apologize, but indeed.
We do not, overall.
We do not do enough.
We could, by and
large, I think, if we
would have sufficient
preventive measures,
eradicate, with really strong
efforts worldwide, nearly
all catastrophic
infectious diseases.
I think there is no
reason to believe
that we could not do that.
I'm not talking
about Alzheimer now.
If we would have even stronger
emphasis on prevention
in heart disease,
cardiovascular disease,
we could at least
reduce it with half.
I am quoting now again
Richard Peto from Oxford--
just retired--
but he always goes around
that we can basically prevent
about 50% of early mortalities.
So in that sense, prevention,
yes, we could do much more.
I missed your second
question but--
- Your opinion about what is
known as the Bredesen Protocols
that Dr. Bredesen publicized
in his book called The End
of Alzheimer's.
- I must say, I am familiar
with the name, the author,
but not with the book,
and so the overall idea
I would have to
discuss with you then
after we have done the
plenary session here.
I'm happy to do so.
- I find you so
intelligent, and thank you,
thank you for all you've stated.
However--
- Tell my wife.
[LAUGHTER]
- I have had my
first knee surgery,
and in my physical therapy
five and three times a week,
they always bring up
blood up to my knee.
And you stated about
the blood in our head.
So again, if we bring
up blood, is that
going to make a difference?
- Well, you see, yes.
The answer is yes.
Your brain is the
organ that needs,
proportionately
speaking, most oxygen.
You can do with a lot of
less oxygen in your heart,
your liver, but your brain, no.
It needs to really
a lot of oxygen.
So the moment you're
awake, you need it,
and if you don't
have it, something
goes wrong with
these neuron cells.
It's as simple as that.
Your knee is probably better
without a bit more blood.
- I'm in my 70s.
I'm old, and I don't
want to grow up.
Thank you.
[LAUGHTER]
- I have-- pleasure to
listen to you today.
I have two fairly
pointed questions.
One, what are your
thoughts on EDTA chelation,
if there are atherosclerotic
conditions that are affecting
brain perfusion, and
then number two, what
are your thoughts on
things like [? HydroGene ?]
or the racetams for increasing
blood flow to the brain?
Ginkgo biloba-- and of course,
there's a million supplements,
but I'm particularly
curious about what
you thought about
[? HydroGene ?] and EDTA,
given that they're both
fairly inexpensive and safe.
- Well, I appreciate
the general question.
Namely, are there
relatively simple ways
to increase blood flow here or
to reduce the negative effects
that we have on
our blood vessels?
And you think of a kind of
omnibus type of effect--
a big effect on the overall
circulation and then
on the brain.
My favorite one there
is, indeed, antioxidants,
because the free radicals--
the ozone, O3, going around--
not only are really quite
harmful to your overall--
to your blood vessels but
also to your brain and neurons
and so on.
And therefore,
sufficient antioxidants,
in one form or another-- we know
that selenium works quite well
in this case--
really has most likely
a very good effect
on preserving
cognitive function.
This has been quite strongly
studied in these nematodes,
in C. elegans, and also
in specific mice that
had oxidative stress
and then were compared
to those who did not have that.
So the overall idea--
I'm not going to go
into the specifics,
but the overall
idea I like, yeah.
- I've seen some
good work done on
the antioxidant astaxanthin--
- Yeah.
- --and how it protects the
form of DHA that crosses
the blood-brain barrier,
therefore having a benefit
on the brain.
But then I was curious if that
would have a vascular effect
versus more of a neurological.
- Yeah, that's always the
question in this case.
I agree with that.
It doesn't.
By the way, if it works,
doesn't matter very much
what the pathway is, but yeah.
- Hello, my name
is Caterina Gates,
and I want to thank you
for being here for us.
I want to thank you for
being here for all of us,
and my name is Caterina Gates.
I have three short questions.
Is it true what
we've heard before,
going to lectures and so on,
that the Alzheimer's is apt
to be passed down from mother
to daughter than from mother
to sons?
And is it also true
that the only way
to diagnose Alzheimer's
is after death when
they look at your brain--
that they take it apart?
And the third one is what is the
commonest in the women in Japan
and the women in Spain?
As you said, they had, at
least, chances of having
Alzheimer's or incidence
of having Alzheimer's.
- Shall we start
with the last one,
and then you lead me
again to the other ones?
The last one-- they live
longer, women, but men
as well, although there
is in both countries,
the difference
between men and women.
But they do not get less
Alzheimer's or dementia.
In fact, when you
look at the pattern,
you saw the pattern with age.
That's very similar whether
you see it in Japan, in Spain--
there is a study in Spain--
and in the US or
in Western Europe.
So there's basically--
I don't think in this
particular instance,
we cannot learn very much from
possible heterogeneity between
populations, which is generally
a very good way to study
particular questions.
Of your two other questions,
what is your most pressing one?
- If it's passed down more
from mothers to daughters
than mothers to sons?
- OK, there is some
evidence that for longevity,
in this case, for life
expectancy-- in fact,
there's quite a recent
published publication on this--
that this, indeed, is
in the maternal line.
For dementia, I do not know of
any evidence in that respect.
- That's good news because
my husband's mother had
Alzheimer's, and the only way to
diagnose at the time she died--
that was back in 2006--
it was-- I don't know if
everyone can hear me--
that it was through
just after death,
if you have the brain in.
I want everybody here, if
you are dealing with someone
with Alzheimer's or are afraid
of maybe someone having it
eventually in your
family at some point--
nobody will take her
brain because you
had to do all that paperwork
ahead of the death here
in this country.
And so here she always
was an organ donor,
and she wanted her brain
to go, and we wanted that,
and it went to waste because
they wouldn't take it.
We looked at all--
called every hospital where
we are here in Boston.
Nobody would take it
because of the paperwork.
- If--
- Anyway.
- --in the more general question
of paperwork and science,
I'm on your side, I must say.
In terms of diagnosis, making
a diagnosis, we are very close,
and we are actually
quite good in making
the diagnosis, also alive.
And I'm not sure--
yet that is important,
because that means
that being alive,
we could study differences, and
we could try to find out why it
is that--
- Well, thank you--
- --being alive.
- --anyway for
everything you do.
- Thank you.
- My name is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a student in
nutritional epi.
So my question is would
you please address
the role of nutrition
and dietary pattern
on the risk factors
you mentioned?
Thank you.
- I think one of the best
summaries would be to say,
all dietary patterns that
are related, particularly
to cardiovascular disease
or vascular factors,
are most likely
involved in that sense,
directly or
indirectly, in dementia
and Alzheimer's disease as well.
This afternoon,
before I came here,
we had a working
group discussion
on carotenoids in Alzheimer's
disease and dementia--
very strong evidence from
a variety of studies there.
And so that would lead
then to particular trials
that you could do in
which you looked then
at people having those or people
not having intake of that.
So yes, there are quite
a number of, I think,
factors that are nutritional
factors that are possibly
involved.
The evidence, though, is, in
overall, not very strong yet.
I emphasize yet because
I think it will be better
and in the bigger
studies we have on this.
I say this a bit
hesitantly, you hear,
but I think one
of these chapters
in the book of
dementia will certainly
be nutrition or nutritional
factors in relation
to the disease.
It will be, I think, a bigger
chapter than the genes.
- Good evening.
My name is
[? Gabriela. ?] Thank you
very much for your
wonderful lecture.
I have a probably
very similar question.
What do you think is the
role of physical inactivity
as related to probably brain
volume and vascularization
and probably the prevention
of Alzheimer's disease?
Thank you.
- I think it's big--
possibly big.
Physical activity is
quite strongly related
to generally all
these risk factors
that I mentioned
for heart disease,
and thereby, indirectly at
least, also for dementia.
But it's also quite
well possible,
and there's increasing
evidence for that,
that there's a direct neuronal
effect of physical activity.
And so direct brain effect,
if I may say so, and so
therefore yes.
I think it's a
very good strategy
to focus on physical
activity or decline
and fight physical inactivity if
you want to prevent Alzheimer's
disease and dementia.
This is something also that
can start early in life.
One of the, I
think, the tragedies
of physical activity-- most
people like it very much when
they are students.
They go and you know and so on.
And then what happens?
Why does that happen?
You get a family and things, and
you cannot do anything anymore
and so on.
But if we would continue
physical activity,
being reasonably physically
active over a lifetime,
I cannot give a quick estimate
of the number of patients with
Alzheimer's that would save,
but I think it would be
considerable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- That brings us to the
end of our questions,
so please join me in
thanking Dr. Hofman.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]